indignación en irán con la muerte de
maxa aminí tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral algo por lo que el
alto comisionado de Naciones Unidas para
los Derechos Humanos ha exigido una
investigación Imparcial
las acusaciones de tortura y malos
tratos deben ser investigadas con
prontitud para garantizar en particular
que su familia tenga acceso a la
justicia y a la verdad las autoridades
deben dejar de perseguir acostar y
detener a las mujeres que no respetan
las normas del jillado
maxam Mini curda de 22 años Fue detenida
mientras estaba de visita enterana la
capital por llevar el velo mal puesto
días más tarde murió tras entrar en coma
cuando estaba en prisión algo que ha
puesto el foco sobre los derechos de las
mujeres ya que el acoso verbal y físico
a las que llevan el yihab suelto por la
policía de la moral es común nuestra
oficina ha recibido numerosos vídeos que
han sido verificados sobre el trato
violento a las mujeres incluyendo
bofetadas en la cara golpes con la porra
y lanzamientos dentro del furgón
policial tras la muerte de amenia varias
ciudades de Irán han visto
movilizaciones lideradas por jóvenes que
exigen justicia y Libertad para vestir
como quieran
deberían quitarla obligatoriedad quien
quiera pueda llevarlo y quien no quiera
no tiene por qué hacerlo y es que el
velo ha estado en el centro del debate
desde el inicio de la revolución iraní
con repetidas protestas contra la
imposición del vestir islámico un
descontento que preocupa al gobierno de
la nación persa altamente represivo en
las movilizaciones que ya se han salvado
con varios muertos